with us now hello to Mr McFadden thanks
for joining us on the program while
they've listened the changing course
that can only be a good thing right
well it's a humiliation for the
chancellor and the Prime Minister I mean
only yesterday the Prime Minister was
giving interviews seeing that she would
stick with this policy it was the right
thing to do and the problem is that the
events of the last 10 days have been
about more than one policy the overall
campaigned effect of this has been to
destroy the Tory party's economic
credibility and even more seriously to
undermine trust in the UK economy and
the fear must be that millions of people
will be paying the price of that for a
long time to come
um yeah but the point is they get it and
they've listened
but this um this policy was not just our
distraction it was emblematic of what
they believe uh which is the if only you
give more wealth to those who already
have it it will trickle down to the rest
of us but that's not how you get
economic growth it's not how a modern
economy Works growth comes from all of
us from the efforts of everyone and our
damaging and Reckless Act will have
undermined trust
yeah the economy yeah not just job
policy not just through one policy but
through the Reckless disregard for the
UK's Economic Institutions from the
treasury to the ubr to the bank of
England all of that has served to damage
the UK's economic credibility and that's
a very Reckless thing to do
but isn't it a sign of a good leader
that they realize when they've made the
wrong decision and you turn on it
but we never supported this policy of
course we I think it's right not to
pursue it but even this morning they
haven't said they won't return to this
they haven't said they don't really
believe in this and remember this policy
was based on the idea that they would
borrow money from those who don't have
wealth to give it to those who already
have wealth and that was the centerpiece
of the mini budget uh 10 days ago is a
matter of values and it's a matter of
Economics uh if you turned on one policy
but they haven't really u-tuned on that
belief and there's no guarantee that
they won't return to this in the future
and the real consequences
that's not my point my point is they've
realized that it's not the right policy
and so a sign of a good leader is to
acknowledge that they've made a mistake
and to
um change the plan
a sign of a good leader would not have
done this in the first place when they
had plenty of warnings that inflation
was already high that pressure on
interest rates was already on the upward
side and they chose
to do a policy based on large-scale
borrowing for unfunded tax cuts and then
the chancellor chose to double down the
day after it or two days after it and
say they would do more of this it'd be
more unfunded tax cuts in the future and
that has caused long-term uh damage to
the UK's economic credibility it
necessitated an extraordinary
intervention from the bank of England it
could cost 65 billion pounds in trying
to prop up our pensions which were in
danger because of what they've done uh
and there's there could be no faith that
the people who brought you these
mistakes can now fix the long-term
damage that they've done
not necessarily I think you may be
conflating issues there the bank of
England's intervention wasn't because
necessarily of the 45p down to 40p
highest rate of tax and you know to go
back to my point about
um strong leaders kirstama only in July
of this year he Sparks a Revolt within
the labor party with his u-turn on the
nationalization of Railways and I put it
to you again that actually strong
leaders realize when they're wrong and
change course
but I agree with you that the bank of
England's intervention wasn't just about
the 45p uh decision it was about the
package as a whole and most of the
package of as a whole is still there so
you're absolutely right to say that okay
the bank of England 65 billion pound
intervention wasn't just about the 45p
ray it was about the idea that when uh
inflation is already high and interest
rates are already on the way up you come
along and you add pressure to both of
those things through a large-scale mini
budget of borrowing 45 billion pounds
for unfunded tax cuts so you're
absolutely right to say that the bank of
England intervention wasn't just about
one policy it was about the package as a
whole and that's why reversing just one
policy in it isn't enough
and what about the second part of my
comment saying that good leaders know
when they need to change direction as
Kirsten
well I don't feel that the events of the
last two days have shown us we've got
good leaders I think they've shown us
we've got Reckless leaders and that's
not a good position for the country for
you acknowledge that when somebody who
is a leader has made the wrong decision
they are a strong leader if they
acknowledge that to move forward I
wouldn't use the word strong uh they've
made a reckless mistake here uh they
were warned about it they pressed ahead
for 10 days it is better that they've
changed their mind to press ahead but
strong is not the verdict I would use
for the leadership that we've seen in
the last 10 days I think Reckless is a
more accurate word had John McDonnell on
the show earlier and he said a lot of
the policies of the labor party at the
moment had built on the shoulders of
Jeremy corbyn do you agree
uh no I think we're going to be a very
different party going into the next
election than we were in 2019 and of
course that's that's the right thing to
do because we had such a bad result then
we've not just got a new leader we've
got a new direction to and both of those
will be necessary if we're going to be
in a position to win which I very much
hope we will be next time
uh chatting to quite a few youngsters
young people I should say when I was up
at Labor Party Conference in Liverpool
last week and they were saying there
should be a role for Jeremy corbyn in
cabinet do you think it's a good idea
uh no I don't but I probably won't
surprise you okay we'll have a different
cabinet and uh or Shadow cabinet and
hopefully cabinet
um but I don't believe that Mr Corbin
will be part of either
should he have the whip returned
uh at some model for the party processes
but uh I can't see that happening unless
there's a change in Attitude on his part
to the appalling circumstances where we
had to be investigated by the equality
and Human Rights Commission that was a
bad period in Labor's history I'm
grateful that we've turned the page on
it now and we've got not only a new
leader but a new Direction and both of
those things were essential